the ring can enslave the minds of men
you must hold to our purpose no matter
what the cost
could I bruise the chopper he Middle
Earth shadow is an epic third-person
open-world action RPG and a follow-up to
the award-winning Middle Earth shadow of
Mordor but if you didn't play that one
silly goose here's a bit you need to
know there's a fella called the Dark
Lord Sauron tis mates the most powerful
bloke around he meant to conquer all
middle-earth with his army hooks some
folk tried to stop him and he didn't
much like that so he killed one named
Italian what that bloke oh that looks
you tricky birdies Italian didn't stay
kill see there's his hell fool who died
ages ago and he's got history with
Sauron something about Sprint's the elf
keeps Italian from cocking it Italian
gives the elf a body to live in and
together they become for our Lord
that's riders and glowy - not smart
ketosis
I know Talia
sir the fried loon is going up against
the Dark Lord and what better way to
take down the Lord of the Rings than
with a ring of the arrived walk possibly
go wrong
the little Katia fools yourself a rig of
power and you're gonna embark on a quest
it'll take you all over Mordor defending
the city of Neenah see doing battle with
sirens Marvin now scoo getting an air
bashing from seal of the Spina even
teaming up with a nice bloke like made a
pop of you aids you're barking up the
wrong tree there mate where the food is
shadow of war is epic the story's ethnic
the characters are epic the open-world
is epic
and if you think I'm saying err big too
much you did wrong right
it's not enough the regions have bored
or ash rocking massive I've got
fortresses action-packed missions
puzzles treasures overloads and heaps of
other stuff hidden all around there's a
ton of stuff to do on top of all the
glorious party violence imagine thing
yes soft sod and you do it all while
looking flash with the river kick your
health might forges for ya dis perfect
swords bows a lot and you've got loads
of skills you can master upgrade swap
out whenever you want
crave Walker I thought he was dead hey
hey and did I mention the Yuke's look at
these bastards
the world's full of old tribes each with
their own rituals and flash beer and
preferred methods of getting into a
scrap and everyone could end up your
loyal follower
oh yeah nemesis what you ain't heard of
the Nemesis system
it's the reason not they will they
forgot officer either that enough one
hour on the Nemesis system creates
unique codes so knows who players get
all the same blokes that's what we need
means I return to furnish you some will
be nice and Charlie others bills ruck is
how you choose to deal with a makes all
the difference does they remember it or
don't they cut a fool up and he might
survive then Fuu got yourself a nemesis
or maybe you extend a war
we had the friendship and kind of
follower Renaud our Lord same thing
really like yours truly and followers a
new to shadow and they add a whole new
dimension to your story what very well
who becomes your nemesis and who becomes
your follow-up matters because you're
building an army to take on sorrow and
it's not just orcs in your army
you've got browse categories droids now
you've got your army but you're getting
a little ants and if you see this flag
just a goofy I think it's time to make a
hawk with base fortress time lads right
that's right and fall really get kooky
and when you all see those wolves
they're not going over there going
through them you take a fortress you
conquer region and you can just smell
them smoke and hatred I think but you'll
deal with him later
there's heaps more I will show you all
this has got me itching to go rip out a
few spots while I'm doing that you
recruiting to follow us fools your army
slay analyses and conquer all of
middle-earth
there's nothing sweet of the big three
easy see you soon
[Music]
you